[Music]
i could be a very wealthy man right now
if i had invested in bitcoin a long time
ago but i don't know anything about
bitcoin i don't really know anything
about investing i might be able to be a
wealthy man if i start investing in
bitcoin now but i need someone to tell
me what the hell bitcoin is which is why
i've brought on the expert bitboy crypto
ben armstrong uh ben if you're not
following his content he's got well over
a million subscribers on youtube he is
the place to go for crypto news crypto
currency trading advice all these things
that i don't know
anything about ben thank you for coming
on
yeah i think thanks for having me uh you
know anytime i get to talk crypto and
especially when i can reach an audience
and maybe doesn't know that much about
it uh it's always a win for me so very
excited to be here you're talking to the
main audience that doesn't know anything
about it namely me the audience of one i
i need you ben if you don't mind to
answer this for me
once and for all allay my fears i have
had
one this sort of luddite uh disposition
which is i'm skeptical of all new
technology and i never would get the new
video game consoles when they came out
and i
i'm i'm an old man then i'm an old man
in a young person's body so
what is bitcoin what is crypto is it
real is it just gambling is it just a
speculative asset or should i start
throwing my money into it
well i i'm glad i'm speaking to uh you
know an old man in a young body as i'm
an old man in an old body so uh you know
i i've always been a little bit of an
early adopter i think a lot of people
would tell you about that uh
you know if you ask them about me in my
life i've always been a little ahead of
the curve on things of technology i i
look ahead and i see what's coming even
if i don't necessarily think it'll be
beneficial for me like you know gaming
is getting absolutely huge i'm not a
gamer uh but we try to take advantage of
that on our channel we talk about
different you know gaming coins and
gaming cryptos and things like that so
uh i understand where you're coming from
i think the majority of people are
skeptical about crypto uh back in 2017
when i really went kind of all in on
crypto uh you know i talked to people
back then whereas just as skeptical then
as you are now the people that listened
to what i was telling them at that time
they're doing very well the people that
didn't listen and remain skeptical well
you know they missed out on a golden
opportunity so i do think it's really
important to differentiate between
bitcoin crypto and blockchain crypto is
kind of the larger arena that all of
that kind of fits
within blockchain is the technology that
underlies a lot of uh the crypto
infrastructure there are some coins out
there crypto projects that aren't
technically blockchain uh they are even
using newer technology like iota as a
coin use something called tangle which
try to wrap your head around that i
don't even know if it's going to work
but um then of course you have bitcoin
which is the first crypto uh or a lot of
people say cryptocurrency i personally
don't use the word cryptocurrency
because
it gives everybody
i think it's really one of the most you
know common misconceptions about crypto
is they're not all currencies like
everybody looks at ethereum and they
says well you know how are people going
to be spending ethereum as a currency
that's not really the what it is you're
really investing in crypto or in
ethereum as a network and the more
successful the network is the more
valuable the coin will be it's not about
trying to replace the dollar with
ethereum now when bitcoin started it was
certainly started with the mission to be
a currency and i think this is really
where that misconception comes from i
like to use digital assets i think
that's a much better term uh for
everything in the space or crypto assets
in some cases so when it comes to
bitcoin its original intention was
written of course by satoshi nakamoto
the uh anonymous uh founder a lot of us
think it's you know a combination of hal
finney and some of these other
cypherpunks it was multiple people that
created it we haven't heard a word from
him and you know since i think 2010 was
his last post so don't know where he is
but he wrote the bitcoin white paper uh
in in late 2008 and what that said uh
the the subtitle was bitcoin uh you know
peer-to-peer electronic currency that
was or electronic cash uh is is the gist
of the byline and so a lot of people
took that to mean that this is going to
be a currency we're all going to pass
back and forth it was created in
response to the 2008 bailouts the
financial crisis
because hey if we're responsible for
ourselves
but the banks and the insurance groups
and all the the auto industry
they don't have to be responsible for
themselves that's not really fair we're
having to foot their bill and we don't
like that so what if we had a way that
we could be in control of our own money
and that's what it started as well it's
a great noble cause i think we would all
agree we don't we want privacy in our
transactions we don't want every single
thing we do track and i think that's
something a lot of people in your
audience can that resonates with them
and they understand that
crypto in a lot of ways it works very
similar to cash in a privacy aspect like
if i want to pay you cash for something
i can go pay you cash and the government
doesn't have to have their nose in that
business uh of course above a certain
amount you would have to disclose that
according to irs but crypto kind of you
know captures that same idea i should be
able to send a transaction without the
government putting their nose uh in the
middle of that but something happened in
the last you know eight years probably
starting around uh maybe less than that
maybe about 2015 to 2016 the narrative
of bitcoin started changing from hey
this is a currency we wanted to replace
the us dollar to now people see its
value uh it's appreciating value over
time it's the greatest appreciating
asset we've ever seen in the history of
mankind some charts will even show you
it's like an infinite rise you know like
the the crate before bitcoin for a penny
was what it started as of course as of
the recording here somewhere between 45
and 50 000 per bitcoin
so the narrative changed to
hey the biggest value is holding it so
now we actually look at bitcoin as
digital gold it is an alternative to
gold i could go over all the reasons why
it's far superior to gold i know i just
did a debate with peter schiff uh that
people can see some of that information
on uh but so it started as a currency
but now it is more digital gold and in
terms of uh an actual crypto currency
we're seeing a lot of different options
arise from that there are several coins
that try to fulfill that still like
bitcoin cash for instance or litecoin or
dash or some of these other ones but
we're also seeing the rise what we call
cbd seeds which are central bank digital
currencies these are
centralized cryptocurrencies that are
just another iteration of your local
central bank
so
that does clarify some things but it
raises about a million more questions
for me as well
now i'm so i'm glad to hear you say that
it's not
really a currency or it's not just a
currency or it's not primarily a
currency because that's been one of my
issues with bitcoin from the very
beginning as i thought i don't really
think this is going to behave like a
currency i don't think people are
investing in it as though it is a
currency i think they're looking at it
more as a speculative asset they they
see it as a thing that they want to put
their money into it because they think
the number is going to go up and then
they're going to have more money so then
the question becomes is this just
the tulip bubble in the netherlands is
this just a bunch of people
who are pouring their money into
something because the number keeps going
up but if there's no real value
underneath it and if there's no
sort of long-standing human interaction
with this thing that can give you
confidence that it's going to have value
is it just going to collapse one day
well
you know and i always got to say this
like eventually it will collapse one day
i mean i don't think it'll be the world
currency for the rest of human
civilization
uh you know there will be a new
technology that comes around one day but
in the short term over the next 50 to 60
years i would say there's very little
chance of that the 55 out of the top 100
banks in the world
more than half have exposure heavy
exposure to crypto uh and we're seeing
more added by the day fidelity recently
just jumped into crypto in a big way
they've already been doing
cryptocustodianship
for a while
you're seeing more and more banks and
hedge funds uh we saw over this little
we call it the mini bear market where
the prices dipped here for bitcoin over
the last few months or on the rise again
but blackrock the biggest you know uh
hedge fund in the world they tripled
their bitcoin holdings during that dip
there uh so there are a lot of big
players we know tesla's bought bitcoin
spacex owns bitcoin microstrategy owns
bitcoin paypal grayscale
at some point when you look at when you
read the tea leaves here it all starts
to add up
crypto adoption is coming and it's
coming pretty quickly uh so there's a
lot of belief underneath crypto
that pushes this forward and of course
you know i do like the way you said you
know or a you know long-standing you
know human interaction because i mean
you could really argue there's not much
difference between bitcoin and the
dollar uh actually you know dollar way
more inflationary uh they just print it
at will i mean a lot of people would say
the world's biggest ponzi scheme is the
us dollar yeah i i i see that point and
so i i'm trying to make these
distinctions so that i don't i don't
want to make a criticism of bitcoin that
could be equally true of gold or equally
true of the dollar why do you point that
out well when you when you get to the
dollars the dollar is sure very
inflationary it's actually very
inflationary right this minute under the
biden administration but it's it's still
backed by a bunch of guns that are held
by the pentagon and if you if you look
at gold
gold it's just a it's just a thing right
it's just a pile of bars but it it can
be turned into jewelry it has been
valued by human beings since basically
the dawn of time people like to look at
it it glitters all nicely people have
confidence in its value
people don't think it's ever going to go
to nothing so so my question then for
bitcoin or crypto more generally is
what am i getting what is the what is
the value beyond if there is one what is
the value beyond it just going up a
little bit i i saw this other related
technology the nft the non-fungible
token which is i i suppose and again i
obviously don't understand this very
well either but it's a way of selling
some image it's a way of selling some
digital property at which i can just
download right now and print out myself
but it's somehow you have ownership of
it then yeah like you can print the mona
lisa but you don't know but you don't
exactly right but so
for it for a digital technology you know
if i were to sell the nft the
non-functional token on a tweet of mine
i guess then someone would own that
tweet but everyone else gets to look at
the tweet too and i just don't i don't
see what the added
value is so what so what am i missing
well i would tell you we're at the very
beginnings of an emerging technology
that
you know
i'm really passionate about
decentralization i think that's
something a lot of your audience you
know i hate the technocracy yeah i speak
out against the big tech i speak out
against the censorship uh the stuff that
happened with uh uh what what was the
app that got taken down the app store
parlor i can't even remember anymore
it's been so long as they took it out
but the stuff that happened with parlor
that's unacceptable yeah
crypto and decentralization and
blockchain are really the way that we
can tie together the internet a lot of
people say well crypto's in the days of
the wild west we know the internet's
still in the days of the wild west when
you have a seven-year-old that can pick
up a phone and look at pornography yeah
we're still in the wild west days of the
internet for sure and blockchain
actually has a lot of ways it can solve
many of those underlying rotten decaying
problems with the internet so we're at
the beginning of this the first time
somebody tripped over a a gold nugget
let's say uh you know i don't know in a
cave or something they look down they
didn't look down at it and say oh you
know what one day that's going to be
using cell phones how cool you know they
didn't they didn't look down they say oh
i can melt this into jewelry you know
how awesome the first people when this
you know when gold on a technology but
when it was emerging you know he said
this is the beginning like people didn't
know what it was going to become down
the road and with crypto this is an
emerging technology the same way you
would have looked at the beginning of
the internet and been like i don't
understand why my company needs a
website it's cool that people can you
know chat on aol instant messenger but
what do i do with this that's where
we're at with crypto and a lot of these
other crypto projects
like ethereum like cardano
they solve a lot of the problems that we
have in society with the internet for
bitcoin specifically this is why i do
believe that bitcoin is more akin to
gold than these other projects because
it doesn't really have a working network
of uh divi projects decentralized
finance projects like ethereum does but
it's all developing so what can you
actually use your bitcoin for i mean the
same thing that you would probably use
gold for to appreciate as an asset with
the development of something called the
lightning network which is a faster way
to send bitcoin transactions uh there
are all kinds of things coming in the
future with bitcoin development that
maybe there will be actual more
functional reasons to hold a bitcoin i
mean right now like you said it is just
based on the fact that you know i like
you said
the dollar is backed by all the guns uh
inside of washington dc and the pentagon
and you know our military well i would
tell you looking at the banks and their
movement into crypto i would tell you
that the money in the bank's coffers are
far more dangerous than guns
that okay this is starting to make sense
to me then because i obviously
empathize with the the demand for
decentralization and i and especially
now as my dollar is basically worth
nothing and i go to the grocery store
and everything all the prices keep going
up i think okay yes i certainly want
that i don't want whether it's the
government or big tech i don't want them
having this
creeping awful surveillance state to
monitor everything i i do or think so
okay i recognize why people would want
to get into bitcoin that way and and i i
see the other point which is yeah maybe
bitcoin itself is not doing anything for
you other than going up and down but the
underlying technology of blockchain this
is going to be very important you know
george gilder
who was reagan's favorite economist
actually
ronald reagan's most cited economist so
george gilder
has been around a very long time he
wrote a book a few years ago called life
after google where he said listen you
young whippersnappers get into this
blockchain because this is the future of
the internet this is going to be the
future architecture of the entire
internet so
okay i get that and then this leads me
to my next question
if bitcoin if crypto if blockchain is
posing a threat to
centralization certain monopolies on
currency and assets if it's
a lot of people are going to be turning
against it so i want to know
how is this thing going to survive the
inevitable regulatory push and who are
the people trying to regulate it
yeah so the people trying to regulate it
i mean it's it's a mixture of the cftc
the sec the treasury you know we call
her janet no telling yellen because
there's no telling how much she's gonna
print or you know recently more you know
we like calling her janet uh felon
yelling as you know she's taking all
kinds of bribes from the banks you guys
may not notice a third of her overall
net worth came over the last year from
zoom cults this is the treasury
secretary
treasury secretary and a third of her
net worth has come over the over the
past she is worth 20 million right now
over seven million dollars of that came
in
this last 365 days from speeches she
gave over zoom calls
which were paid by banks
many i don't have the list right in
front of me of the banks that actually
paid her
citi was definitely one of them though
uh that paid her so you know a third of
your income or your net worth not your
income your net worth came over zoom
calls from banks you wonder who she's
trying to protect uh there's a reason
she's pushing against crypto but they're
all arguing over who it should be now uh
here at bitboy crypto uh we are pushing
hard we're actually trying to create the
first crypto lobbying group that's
something we're trying to do to push to
get more favorable crypto regulation and
help people understand it we've also i
went and spoke with the texas state
house of representatives who are we find
the state representatives are great we
we're going to be speaking to alabama
soon we've got several other ones i go
give a presentation talk about the
beneficial you know elements of
innovating in blockchain the new space
race between us and china is going to be
over blockchain we believe and so trying
to get that favorable innovation is
something we need to push these states
to do on the federal level they're all
owned by the banks ninety percent of our
politicians are owned by the banks uh so
the fact is it's going to be hard from
that standpoint to really get favorable
regulation but you can't ban bitcoin
people may have seen like china banning
bitcoin mining or you know we make jokes
about banning bitcoin because we know
there's no way to ban open source
computer code what they can do
is they can come after the on and off
ramps to exchanges but we also know that
coinbase is a highly regulated exchange
and they're part of what we call the
financial cartel which is a lot of the
biggest banks including uh some some
hong kong tycoons where some of the
original investors in something called
the digital currency group
that actually owns a large portion of
coinbase and so coinbase is kind of the
chosen financial cartel uh exchange and
so now that doesn't mean you shouldn't
use it it's the easiest way to use uh
crypto or to buy crypto for a person
that's new the coinbase app
but you know
coinbase is not going away the
government's not going to be able to
regulate and we saw with the
infrastructure bill they had a lot of
stuff that was very negative towards
crypto
and before it's it you know it's going
to leave the house again and get you
know approved all that stuff's going to
be fixed and actually i think it was the
i think it was i can't remember the sec
i can't remember exactly who it was said
that in the current state of the bill
that they wouldn't even legislate it as
it's written because it's unenforceable
so uh we don't know who's in charge of
crypto we're a big advocate for having
an independent not i mean there will be
politicians on it i'm sure but having a
a separate
commission or council
that is over crypto with people there
that actually understand it at least a
little bit uh cynthia lummus uh you know
senator from wyoming she's a person that
definitely understands bitcoin
understands it wyoming's you know very
pro crypto uh she's definitely a person
that you know she was also uh you know
wrote on one of the amendments to the
bill that didn't get passed but had a
lot of favorable stuff for bitcoin so
there are some politicians who do
understand it in inkling uh some
understand a little more but the vast
majority of people trying to regulate
crypto right now
don't know what they're talking about
and we've seen this the sec the citc and
the treasury they're all arguing who is
in control of crypto which is just
pushing this you know it's your common
you know political nightmare so well
this is true of most issues i found in
washington is that the people making the
rules and the laws don't have any idea
what they're talking about whatsoever
and so i'm i'm not surprised that crypto
which genuinely is somewhat complicated
is eluding them so speaking of who's in
control of bitcoin you mentioned this
name earlier
but i i want to go a little deeper
who is
satoshi nakamoto oh satoshi nakamoto so
this is the guy
we say the guy no i i got into bitcoin
first and uh
in 2012
and so first bitcoin i bought was it was
it 12 i kind of backed into it uh i was
not using the silk road like a lot of
people who got hit at that time i was
actually buying a software for a
business that i needed and for those for
people who haven't followed it the silk
road because there was a major legal
case about this the silk road was this
sort of
network of dubious legality that was
outside of the main internet it was on
like the secret internet yeah
the dark web you had to log into all
these different things to access it and
this is one of the places where bitcoin
really began to flourish
it did so it's a little bit of a black
eye on bitcoin that one of the things
that really pushed it into the spotlight
was such a negative thing where people
were you know buying nefarious you know
drug i mean but if people want to feel
better about it just know there's a guy
out there that paid 30 bitcoin for some
troops you know so you know
by the way
i mean people can buy drugs on the dark
where i guess now they shut it down but
they could have bought drugs on the dark
web with bitcoin or they could have
walked down the street in chicago and
paid cash for it too so you know this is
not just a total black eye on on bitcoin
so but we do look at it kind of like
that but it was one thing that caused
you know bitcoin to to flourish for real
um but you know when i first got in uh i
remember reading an article about this
guy satoshi nakamoto and at that point
like they were still thinking it was
just some random japanese guy uh which
was so funny the education that we
provide on our channel at bitly crypto
like it wasn't out there during those
times it's hard to learn about bitcoin
uh so
over many years like we put a lot of
stuff together and i'm of the opinion i
feel very strongly that uh satoshi
nakamoto is actually a combination of
many of the what they call the
cypherpunks it was a group of people
that included julian assange
craig wright uh hal finney uh nick zabo
many of these early kind of innovators
in the world of crypto uh and
you know they created this thing called
bitcoin through uh something called
bitcoin talk forum this was the where
they would go back and forth
how finney was the first person to
receive a bitcoin transaction or
transfer that's why a lot of people
think he was probably the one now how
finney has passed away he had a disease
and died and many of the other
candidates for being uh satoshi nakamoto
have also passed away which you know
there may be a little conspiracy there
dave kliman is a guy that people people
look into his death was very suspicious
he's associated with craig wright who
claims to be he he outright claims he
created bitcoin but no one believes
that's true a lot of people think it's
maybe because he was good friends and
partners with dave clyman who you know
could have been satoshi and then he died
of you know mysterious circumstances
which is why
craig writes out there saying i did it
because he knows the real creator can't
come out and say it but here's the
important thing
but before you go on though i think this
merits a little more discussion because
okay i had heard this
that you know satoshi nakamoto is is
probably multiple people and and a lot
of the people who it could have been
have died under very strange
circumstances i have a pal of mine who
floated call it a conspiracy theory
floated this idea that john mcafee had
something to do with with the
development of bitcoin he did seem to
have a lot of money in bitcoin at one
point he died under infamously suspected
circumstances saying they're gonna kill
me they're gonna kill me and then he
committed suicide allegedly uh so
regardless of whether mcafee was
involved or not
what does this mean i i just i suppose
what what really worries me about all of
this is
john mcafee dies
forget about bitcoin for a second john
mcafee dies and he says they're going to
whack me people are going to come and
kill me and say it was a suicide and
then he allegedly commits suicide
jeffrey epstein we all joke about it we
say epstein didn't kill himself because
no one thinks epstein killed himself but
we just say like oh ha ha ha you know
the the nefarious forces of this world
murdered this man and they'll get away
with it and then and then you get to
satoshi nakamoto and a bunch of these
dudes who allegedly created this
world-changing new digital asset
wind up dead and there are questions of
did they were they killed by state
actors were they killed by non-state
actors and we all just kind of brushed
that off as oh well that's what happens
you know if you're very powerful you'll
be assassinated by
some people i mean that
we should take a moment and that is a
very scary prospect
oh it is for sure and this happens and
you know it is very sad that we live in
a world where we laugh about
jeffrey epstein and not because i mean
we laugh because it's it's comical to
believe that he hung himself everyone
knows everyone outright in the public
everyone knows he didn't hang himself
but i will tell you a a story which is
uh i know a person who was a very high
level
uh you know a person in the military
someone who had a lot of international
kills under his belt and this is a
person i said the name people
they might not know who it is but if
they did a little research you know
there's been stuff out about him and you
know he said one of his
things he missed the most one of his
biggest regrets
uh in the military and as basically a
person that uh you know had a lot of
international kills uh 50 to 60 i
believe
uh he said that uh he was very irritated
he never got a stateside kill
[Laughter]
you have to think you have to think
about this
there's literally a person out there
responsible for killing jeffrey epstein
yeah there's literally someone out there
hillary clinton by the way so you know
no i'm i'm judging i i didn't say it i'm
not allowed to say that you know
i didn't hear that but uh
regardless of you know let's just
imagine hillary clinton didn't even
exist and that wasn't a meme itself that
someone out there literally was
responsible for the actual kill right
someone went into that cell john mcafee
who i know personally i met john mac or
i haven't met him in person but we've
done several uh three or four interviews
together uh and i know people that know
him very well and i can tell i'm pretty
sure he didn't have anything to do with
the beginnings of bitcoin but he knew a
lot he certainly knew a lot someone went
into that cell and murdered him
and that's a very dark proposition to
believe that we you know we talk about
the control and we talk about the
censorship there are literally people
working for these people who are going
and doing these kills uh people are
involved in this and so i do have to say
that but on on the greater subject here
i i will say that
there's a lot of suspicious stuff around
many of the people floating around the
beginnings of bitcoin for what we know
but i still believe that the number one
person responsible was hal finney
there's a lot of evidence of that and he
actually died of natural causes he did
have a disease and he did die and but i
think it's kind of a perfect storm
i think it's a perfect storm of
the best thing possible now certainly i
wouldn't want to wish death on on anyone
but the best possible case for satoshi
nakamoto
for bitcoin is that he has passed away
he owns anywhere between 600 000 to one
million bitcoin he would actually when
bitcoin goes over i think fifty five
thousand like it was before so as you
know nakamoto technically would be the
richest man in the world
by the public numbers you know there's
people who know more money but that's a
different story uh but you know with
with uh you know him passing away that
means
a couple different things it means that
bitcoin will never move so that's like a
million out of the circulating supply
but it means there's nobody to speak for
bitcoin so there's no that's been one of
the most beautiful things he's like a
folk hero satoshi satoshi nakamoto he
can't come out and tell you what his
vision was he can't tell you guys admit
this is a currency not his gold he can't
come out and tell you like you know what
guys i actually don't like the way that
the volunteers have been developing
bitcoin lately there's nobody in that
role and if you look at a theory of
vitality but he says stuff all the time
that makes the ethereum miners upset or
the community upset you look at you know
charles hoskinson with cardano or brad
garlinghouse with xrp you know there are
certain things they say that a lot of
people don't like bitcoin doesn't have
that so it's really been the perfect
storm of allowing bitcoin to flourish
without you know someone having to get
attacked for it and so i i don't believe
like personally look i'm you know i'm
all for conspiracy theories that aren't
really conspiracy theories you know we
we know a lot of stuff that people towed
out there as conspiracy theories are
actually facts uh like the jeffrey
epstein thing for sure
but when you look at bitcoin i actually
believe in a little more wholesome like
it was created the creator actually died
ultimately you know that's great for
bitcoin don't wish death upon him but
it's great for the future of bitcoin and
that uh you know not having someone to
speak for has been extremely beneficial
that's right it'll it allows it to be
stable not not even just in the numbers
and and it's in its uh you know the
actual numbers of bitcoin but in the in
the narrative the narrative is very
important too
is this one guy's weird pet project or
is this something that really now
belongs
to everybody
i have so many more questions i have so
many more angles i want to take this
down i have so many different
investing tips that i want to ask but
we gotta leave it there thank you very
much ben armstrong
bitboy crypto go check out his channel
it's already got lots and lots of
subscribers but go add some more
subscribers to that and find out more
answers to questions that i clearly am
not able to answer though i'm better
able to answer them now after talking to
you thank you ben
thanks for having me appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
you